hello and welcome to see opening
webmasters no kids just not a good
schooling and subscribe let's see i
remember Kings Indians being played
Grandmaster but doesn't have the name
listed so and see what's no kid is doing
c6 ok looking's in the end of time and x
equals g6 knowledge is of course
possible addition playing for some
queenside expansion sure really how this
should be played maybe try it somewhere
not sure maybe he can take on c4 and
play 75 note into that allow each size
comes into a consideration a little bit
more really okay
takes much Aoife ok so my g5 is a movie
allows me to play I can also take and
then don't know if I what's going on
here I did you fall Lucifer extremely
strange so he's giving up the exchange
even Jake yes so let the tick tick first
things later or something like that and
so probably will take with the with the
bishop to have some kind of activity at
least so now i can go nitey form i'm not
sure i mean i don't have to do this I
can also just try to make this this this
pink side in we come ok so should here
looks quite logical quintal Queen here's
also a google trying to take and have
Queen to h3 available 95 not exactly a
movies probably so happy about but you
have to so bring the Queen over
hmm yeah I'm still not threatening much
should be Chappelle sorry the night on
if age is that are covering that ok well
the duty porn ah ah I like that's what
happens when you take the game not
really serious anymore you think okay
this will be a wind light whatever you
do because this is so bad okay I mean
the things I still think it's not super
clear because blacks position was so
utterly garbage before but I might still
have some chances even after blundering
of for peace okay under the other one so
what's the deal with the ship g-46
doesn't threaten much queen age 40
probably have
a bishop d flow i can play and crazy
just crazy
ok step lost ok take a look chicks and
the room ready I am check
check check check ok at least I didn't
get one didn't get checkmated I mean it
to talk I mean if you from the beginning
of the game it's kind of it's really bad
them what I would I folded into this
game ok
time morning okay let's wait for you to
win this ending I'm blundell you this
pawn otherwise I don't know what's going
on what a frustrating game okay check
check check check okay where is the
idiot of the day price goes to media
after this joke of the game unbelievable
and why white wings with whatever IM
really and I just blundered the PCN one
move here can just play 96 and and it
was even even worse before probably I
mean allowing this is amazing really
amazing like it's just completely lost
in okay yeah the ship p3m is probably
stronger because it threatens 9h seven
well but having a KH oh it's not bad
just have to avoid you to blunder the
PCN you laughter that things are not
entirely clear problem you should be
three is unclear and whatnot and that
really shows that the column sometimes
can play really care uh turn on switch
and you still can use once you can play
with I mean that's it's always possible
check check
now the ending of lost but the way you
played it I wasn't even sure I mean okay
I have the computer doesn't doesn't
doesn't change anything great still if I
don't blunder the H pawn is it is it so
easy now probably it is you can we can
coordinate this quite well well that's a
really frustrating in this is this
opening and is the island okay then
that's not great for black but it's
prolly quite playable somehow but here
at least you have to rule 98 and
northern now this is this motif ok yeah
ok yeah this is this is a much better
threatening night h7 it's probably the
end mediately the engine wants to take
which shows that night h7 of such a
strong thread and this looks really bad
I give take away points led by as always
what I hate the most in this game she
really gets like them each opponent like
they're here and take the point it's
simple and you know and then you use
still screw that out by plundering
blundering apiece okay thanks for